[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ERIK DEMAINE: All right
welcome back to 006,
Dynamic Programming.
We're now in step
two out of four--
going to see a bunch
more examples--
three more examples of
dynamic programming--
longest common subsequence,
longest increasing subsequence,
and kind of a made
up problem from 006,
alternating coin game.
And through those
examples, we're
going to explore a
few new ideas, things
we haven't seen in action
before yet-- dealing
with multiple sequences,
instead of just one;
dealing with substrings
of sequences,
instead of prefixes
and suffixes;
parent pointers so we
can recover solutions,
like in shortest paths.
And a big one, which will
mostly be fleshed out
in the next lecture, is
subproblem constraint
and expansion.
This is all part of
the SRTBOT paradigm--
remember, subproblems,
relations, topological order,
base case, original
problem, and time.
Here is subproblems
and relations.
I've written down both
what these things are
and the key lessons we got from
the first dynamic programming
lecture.
Namely, we want to split up
our problem into multiple
subproblems, and if your
input is a sequence--
that's the main case
we've seen so far--
like the bowling
problem, for example,
then the natural
subproblems to try
are prefixes, suffixes,
or substrings.
Prefixes and suffixes are nice,
because there's few of them.
There's only a linear
number of them.
In general, we want
a polynomial number.
Sometimes you can get
away with one of these.
They're usually about the same.
Sometimes you need substrings.
There's quadratically
many of those.
Then, once you set up
the subproblems, which--
it's easy to set
up some problems,
but hard to do it right--
to test whether you
did it right is,
can I write a
recurrence relation
that relates one subproblem
solution to smaller subproblems
solutions?
And the general
trick for doing this
is to identify some feature
of the solution you're
looking for.
So you're trying to
solve some subproblem,
and you try to ask a question
whose answer would let you
reduce to a smaller subproblem.
So if you can figure out
what that question is,
and that question only has a
polynomial number of answers,
then boom-- and you've
only got polynomial number
of subproblems, then you will
get a polynomial running time.
So I have, I think,
another way to say this.
We just locally brute
force all possible answers
to whatever question
we come up with,
as long as there's
polynomially many.
And then each of them is going
to recursively call the smaller
subproblems, but
because we memoize,
we'll only solve
each subproblem once.
And so on the end,
the running time
will be, at most, the
number of subproblems
times the non-recursive
work done in that relation.
For that to work, of course, the
relations between subproblems
must be acyclic, so
we'd like to give
an explicit topological order.
Usually it's a
couple of for loops.
But this is a topological
order in the subproblem
DAG, which I defined somewhat
informally last time.
the.
Vertices are
subproblems, and I want
to draw an edge from a smaller
problem to a bigger problem,
meaning that, if evaluating
b in this relation calls a,
then I'll draw an
arrow from a to b,
from the things I need
to do first to the things
I'll do later.
So then topological
order will be
ready-- by the time
I try to compute b,
I will have already computed a.
And of course, the relation
also needs base cases.
And then sometimes the original
problem we want to solve
is just one of
those subproblems.
Sometimes we need
to combine multiple.
We'll see that today.
So that's a review
of this framework.
And let's dive into
longest common subsequence.
This is kind of a
classic problem.
It even has
applications to things
like computational biology.
You have two DNA sequences.
You want to measure
how in common they are.
One version of that--
might see other
versions in recitation--
called edit distance-- this is
a simplest, cleanest version,
where I give you two sequences--
I have an example here.
So for example, it could
be a sequence of letters.
So my first sequence
spells hieroglyphology--
study of hieroglyphs.
And second sequence
spells Michelangelo.
And what I'd like
is a subsequence.
So remember, substring has
to be some continuous range,
some interval.
Subsequence-- you
can take any subset
of the letters in your
sequence or any subset
of the items in your sequence.
So you can have
blanks in between.
You can skip over items.
And so what we want is
the longest sequence
that is a subsequence of
both the first string,
the first sequence,
and the second string.
And if you stare at
this long enough,
the longest common subsequence--
I don't think it's
unique, but there
is a longest common sequence,
which is hello hiding in there.
And that is a longest
common subsequence.
So given that input, the
goal is to compute hello,
or whatever the longest
common subsequence is.
So we're given-- write
this down carefully--
given two sequences.
Let me name them
A and B. We want
to find the longest
sequence L that's
a subsequence both A and B. So
that's the problem definition,
and we're going to
see how to solve
it using dynamic programming.
And whereas, in the
bowling problem,
we just had a single
sequence of numbers--
the values of the bowling pins--
here we have two sequences.
And so we need a new trick.
Before, we said, OK, if our
subproblems-- or sorry--
if our input consists
of a single sequence,
we'll try prefixes,
suffixes, or substrings.
Now we've got two
sequences, so somehow we
need to combine multiple
inputs together.
And so here's a general trick--
subproblems for multiple inputs.
It's a very simple trick.
We just take the product,
multiply the subproblem spaces.
OK.
In the sense of cross product
of sets, and in particular,
from a combinatorial
perspective--
so we have two inputs,
the first sequence
A and the second sequence
B. For each of them,
there's a natural choice, or
there's three natural choices.
We could do one of these.
I will choose suffixes
for A and suffixes for B.
You could do some
other combination,
but that would be
enough for here.
And then I want to
multiply these spaces,
meaning the number
of subproblems
is going to be the product
of the number of suffixes
here times the number
of suffixes here.
And in other words,
every subproblem in LCS
is going to be a
pair of suffixes.
So let me write that down.
So for LCS, our
subproblems are L of i, j--
this is going to be the
longest common subsequence--
of the suffix of A starting
at i and the suffix of B
starting at j.
And just to be clear
how many there are,
I'll give the
ranges for i and j--
not going to assume
the sequences
are the same length,
like in the example.
So I'll write lengths of
A and lengths of B. I like
to include the empty suffix.
So when j equals the length
of B that's 0 items in it,
because that makes for
really easy base cases.
So I'd like to include
those in my problems.
So that was the S in SRTBOT.
Now I claim that set subproblems
is enough to do a relation--
recursive relation among them.
So I'd like to solve
every subproblems L i, j.
Relation is actually
pretty simple,
but it's maybe not so obvious.
So the idea is, because
we're looking at suffixes,
we should always
think about what
happens in the first
letter, because if we
remove that first letter,
then we get a smaller suffix.
If you're doing prefixes,
you should always
look at the last letter.
Either one would work
for this problem.
So we're doing suffixes.
So we look at A of i
and we look at B of j.
That's the first letter in
the suffix A starting at i
and the suffix B starting at j.
And there are two cases.
They could be
equal or different.
I think the easier
case to think about is
when they're different.
So like in hieroglyphology
and Michelangelo,
if we look at the whole
string, say, the first letter
in the top one is H. The
first letter in the second one
is M. Those are
different letters,
so clearly, one of
those letters is not
in the common subsequence,
because they don't match.
I can't start with an H.
Well, I can start with an H,
I could start with an M,
but I can't start with both.
One of those letters
is not in the output.
In this example, it's M.
But I don't know which one,
so I have this question.
I want to identify
some question.
And the question is, should I--
do I know that the H is
not in the answer or do
I know that M is
not in the answer--
the final longest
common subsequence?
We don't know which,
so we'll just try both.
And then we're
trying to maximize
the length of our
common subsequence,
so we'll take the max of L i
plus 1 j and L i, j minus 1.
So the intuition
here is one of--
at least one of Ai and
Bj is not in the LCS.
Got this wrong.
j plus 1-- sorry--
thinking about
substrings already.
Yeah.
These are the beginning points,
so I want exclude the i-th
letter--
so if Ai is not in, then I
want to look at the suffix
starting at i plus 1.
If Bj is not in, then I
want to look at the suffix
starting at j plus 1.
So the indices are
always increasing
in the function calls.
And the other case is
that they're equal.
So this one I have a little
bit harder time arguing.
I'm going to write the
answer, and then prove
that the answer is correct.
Here I claim you don't
need to make any choices.
There's no question
you need to answer.
You can actually
guarantee that Ai and Bj
might as well be in the
longest common subsequence.
And so I get one point for
that and then I recurse
on all the remaining letters--
so from i plus 1 on
and from j plus 1 on.
Why is this OK?
Well, we have A, B. We're
starting at position i,
and starting at
position j for B.
Think of some optimal
solution, some longest
common subsequence.
So it pairs up
letters in some way.
This would be some non-crossing
pairing between equal letters.
So first case is
that maybe i and j
aren't paired with anything.
Well, that's silly,
because if they're not
paired with anything,
you have some bearing
on the rest of the items.
You can add this pair, and that
would be a longer subsequence.
So that would be
a contradiction.
If we're taking-- imagining some
hypothetical optimal solution,
it has to pair one of
these with something.
Maybe it pairs i with
something else, though.
Well, if we have a
longest common subsequence
that looks like that, I can
just instead pair i with Bj.
If I had this pairing,
I'm actually not using any
of these letters, so why don't
I just use this letter instead?
So you can argue there is the
longest common subsequence that
matches Ai with
Bj, and so then we
can guarantee by
that little proof
that we get one point
for matching them up--
that we don't have to
max this with anything.
OK, so two cases--
pretty simple formula.
And then we're basically done.
We just need to fill
in the rest of SRTBOT.
So next is topological order.
So this I'll write as for loops.
Because I'm dealing
with suffixes,
we want to start with
the empty suffixes,
and then work our way to
larger and larger suffixes.
So this might seem backwards.
If you're doing prefixes, it
would be an increasing order.
There's all sorts of orders.
You could flip the i and j.
It's very symmetric, so
it doesn't really matter.
But anything that's generally
decreasing i and j is good.
Then we have base cases.
These are when one of
the sequences is empty.
I don't care how many items are
in B, but if A has no items,
there's no common subsequence.
It's empty.
And same for no
matter how big A is,
if I have exhausted
the B string--
I start from beyond
the last item--
then I should get 0.
Then the original problem
we want to solve is L 0, 0--
that's just the
longest common sequence
of the entire A
and the entire B--
and time.
OK, so for time, we need to know
how many subproblems there are.
It's A plus 1 times B plus 1.
I'll just call that theta
A, B. Assume these are not
empty subsequences.
So this is the number
of subproblems.
And then what we care about
is, how much time do we
spend for each sub problem
in evaluating this recurrence
relation?
So we ignore the cost
to recursively call
these L's, because they
are smaller subproblems.
They're already dealt
with when I multiply
by the number of subproblems.
So I just care about this max
computation and this equality
check, and we'll say those
each cost constant time.
So this is quadratic time.
If the two strings are
size n, this is n squared.
In general, it's the product
of the two string sizes.
And that's longest
common substring--
so pretty straightforward.
Other than this little
argument understanding
the case when they're
equal, the easy case where
they're unequal, we just try
the only two things we could do.
One of Ai and Bj is not in the
longest common subsequence,
so what I like to say is
we guess which of those
is the correct one that
is not in the longest
common subsequence.
And if we guess that
it's in A, then we'll
recurse on that side.
If we guess that it's in
j, then we'll recurse on--
by increasing j.
I'd like to assume--
not really-- that we always
make the correct guess,
that we made the correct
choice, whether it's i or j.
Now, we don't actually
know how to do that,
so instead, we brute force.
We try both of them, and
then, because we're trying
to maximize, we take the max--
just another way of
thinking about it.
But overall, very
straightforward-- the only
added complication here is we
had to deal with two sequences
simultaneously, and we
just took the product
of those-- pretty easy.
In general, if you have some
constant number of sequences,
you can afford to do this.
You'll still get polynomial.
But of course, once
you go to n sequences,
you can't afford this.
You would an n to
the n behavior,
so that's a limit to
how far you could go.
Two sequences is
fine, three sequences
is fine, but n sequences--
there probably is no
polynomial time algorithm
for this problem.
Cool-- I want to
show you an example.
I have an example here.
I didn't want to try
out hieroglyphology
versus Michelangelo, so I
came up with another example.
Their habit is to say hi.
So the longest common
subsequence of there and habit
is HI.
And it's a giant--
well, not that giant-- it looks
kind of like a grid graph.
The base cases are out here,
because those correspond--
each of these nodes
is a subproblem,
and this corresponds to, what is
the longest common subsequence
between EIR and ABIT?
And it should be I. It's
the only letter they have
in common, and that's
why there's a 1 here
to say that the longest
common subsequence has
a 1-- has size 1.
The base cases are when
either their has been emptied
or when habit has been
emptied, so those all have 0's
on the outside.
And then the problem we
care about is this one.
It's their versus habit.
Claim is the length is 2.
And what I've drawn in here are
what I'll call parent pointers,
like we talked about with BFS,
and shortest paths, and so on.
So we had this choice--
sometimes we had a choice--
on whether we recursed
here or recursed here
was the best thing to do.
I'll draw in red the arrow
from L i, j-- sorry-- to L
i, j from one of
these in this case.
And in this case,
there was no choice,
but I'll still draw
in red that arrow.
So these diagonal edges
are exactly the cases
where the letters match.
Here H equals H.
I equals I here,
so I draw this diagonal edge.
That's that first case,
where the letters are equal,
and so I recurse by
increasing i and j.
That's why I get
a diagonal edge.
There's also one over
here, where T equals T.
So for those, we're
getting a 1 plus.
You see this 1 is 1
larger than the 0.
This 2 is 1 larger than the 1.
This 1 is one larger than the 0.
And for every other
vertex, we are rehearsing
this way and this way.
We see what those two numbers
are, and we take the max.
So this whole diagram
is just filled in by--
for each position,
where they're not equal.
We look at the guy below.
We look at the guy to the right.
Those are the slightly
smaller substrings.
We look at those values.
We take the max.
As long as you compute
this in a generally
right-to-left and bottom-up
fashion, whenever you're
trying to compute
a guy, you will
have the-- its predecessors
already computed.
That's the topological
order of this graph.
And then, at the end, we
get our answer, which is 2.
And now, if we pay attention
to where we came from--
for example, this vertex had
to come from this direction--
2 is the max of 2 and 1,
so I highlight the 2 edge.
And if I follow this path,
there should be a unique path
to some base case.
We don't know which one.
And in this case,
the diagonal edges
correspond to my
matching letters.
So there's the H here,
followed by the I here.
And so HI is our longest
common substring.
In general, we just
follow these pointers
backward-- the red pointers--
and we get our answer.
So not only do we compute
the length of the LCS,
but we actually can find the
LCS using parent pointers.
And this is a concept you can
use in most dynamic programs,
including all the
ones from today.
OK, any questions about LCS?
All right-- perfectly clear
to everyone in the audience.
Now we move onto longest
increasing subsequence, which--
did I lose a page here?
I just disordered them.
OK, this problem has
almost the same name,
but is quite different
and behavior--
longest increasing subsequence--
LIS, instead of LCS--
both famous problems, examples
of dynamic programming.
Here we're just given one
sequence, like carbohydrate.
So this is a
sequence of letters,
and I want to find the longest
subsequence of this sequence
that is increasing--
strictly increasing,
let's say-- so in this
case, alphabetically.
I could include CR, for
example, but not CB.
That would be a
descending subsequence.
In this example,
the right answer--
or a right answer is abort.
There aren't very many English
words that are increasing,
but there are some, and I
looked through all of them.
As I just implemented
this dynamic program
we're about to write down,
it took me like two minutes
to write down the
DP, and then more
work to read the dictionary
and look for cool examples.
So in general, we're
given some sequence A,
and we want to find the longest
increasing subsequence of A--
the longest sequence that
is increasing, strictly.
We could use the same thing to
solve not strictly increasing,
but--
so here things are going
to be a little trickier.
It's easy, in that we just
have a single sequence.
So again, we think, OK,
let's look at our chart here.
We could try prefixes,
suffixes, or substrings.
I personally prefer suffixes.
Jason prefers prefixes.
Whatever you prefer is fine, but
always, generally, start there,
because there's nothing
in this problem that
makes me think I need to
delete things from both ends.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah-- question?
AUDIENCE: Isn't the answer
to this problem always 26?
ERIK DEMAINE: Is the
answer always, at most, 26?
Yes, if you're dealing
with English words--
so when I say sequence here,
this is a sequence of arbitrary
integers--
word size integers.
So there you can have
a ton of variety.
This is just for the fun of
examples, I've drawn this.
But even if the answer is
26, finding that longest
common subsequence is--
the obvious algorithm would be
to take all substrings of size
26, which is n to the 26.
We're going to do much
faster than that here.
N squared time.
And then, if you remove
the strictly increasing,
then it can be
arbitrarily large.
OK, so let's try to do this.
Maybe I won't be so pessimistic
to write attempt here.
Let's just go for it.
So I want some subproblems, and
I'm going to choose suffixes.
So I'm going to define L of i
to be the longest increasing
subsequence of the suffix
of A starting at i.
That's the obvious thing to do.
And now I'm going to leave
myself a little space,
and then I'd like a
relation on these.
So I'd like to say
what L of i is.
And what do I have to work with?
Well, I have live
things larger than i.
Those would be smaller suffixes.
But let's go back to, what
is a question that I could
ask about this subproblem
that might help me figure out
what the longest increasing
subsequence looks like?
So we're looking at a--
here's A from i on.
Longest increasing subsequence
is some subsequence.
And we'd like to
remove letter i.
Now, when we do that,
there are two choices.
Maybe i is in the longest
increasing subsequence,
or it's not in.
So the question I
would like to answer
is, is i in the longest
increasing subsequence of A--
of A from i onwards?
This is a binary question.
There are two options--
so again, just like before.
And so I can brute
force those two options.
And then I want the longest one,
so I'm going to take the max.
So I'd like to take the max
of something like Li plus 1.
So in the case that I don't put
i in the solution, that's fine.
Then I just look at i plus 1 on,
and recursively compute that,
and that would be my answer.
And the other
option is that I do
put i in the longest increasing
subsequence, so I do 1
plus the rest L i plus 1.
If I close this
brace, this would
be a very strange recurrence,
because this is always
bigger than this one.
There's something wrong
here, and the something wrong
is I haven't enforced
increasing at all.
There's no constraints here.
It's just saying, well, I'll
i put in, and then I'll do
whatever remains, and I'll
pray that that's increasing--
probably won't be, because
indeed, if i is a letter--
or is a number that is
strictly greater than i plus 1,
then this will be wrong.
So I really can't
always do this.
I could check whether i plus
1 is in the answer, but some--
but I don't.
I can check whether the letter
i is less than letter i plus 1.
But maybe I put this in the
longest increasing subsequence
and then I put this in the
longest increasing subsequence,
and so I need to
compare these two items.
But I don't know when
that's going to happen.
Things seem really hard.
And indeed, there's no way,
from this subproblem definition,
to write down a relation.
But there is a slight
tweak to this definition
that makes it work.
So the trouble we have
here-- and this is the idea
of subproblem constraints
or conditions--
the trouble we have
is, when we recursively
compute the longest increasing
subsequence on the remainder,
we don't know the first
item in that answer.
Maybe it's i plus 1.
Maybe it's some guy over here.
If we knew who it
was, then we could
compare that item to item i.
And so what we'd like to
do is add a constraint
to the subproblem that somehow
lets us know where the longest
increasing subsequence starts.
So what I would like to say is
long as increasing subsequence
of that suffix that
starts with A of i.
So in other words,
it includes A of i.
This was a separate question.
OK, this is a bit of
a funny constraint.
It changes the problem.
It's no longer what
we want to solve.
If you think about
the original problem,
before, it was solving L of 0.
We just want the longest
increasing subsequence
of the whole thing.
Now it's not necessarily L of 0.
L of 0 means, what is the
longest increasing sub sequence
of the whole sequence A that
includes the first letter of A?
And maybe we do include
the first letter of A,
maybe we don't we don't
know where the longest
increasing subsequence starts.
Here, for example, it didn't.
It started at the second letter.
But conveniently, it's
OK that we don't know,
because that's just
another question we could
ask is, where do we start?
Where might the LIS start?
Could start at the first
letter, second letter,
third letter-- there's
only n choices,
and let's just take
the max of all of them.
So before I get to the relation,
let's solve this problem.
I just want the max
of L of i for all i.
I guess we've been
writing size of A here.
OK, the maximum will
be the overall longest
increasing subsequence.
So if I could find longest
increasing sub sequence that
includes the first letter, or
the longest one that includes
the second letter, and so on--
so it starts at
the first letter,
starts at the second
letter-- then this max
will be the longest overall.
This subproblem is not
what I really wanted,
but it's still good
enough, because it lets
me solve my original problem.
And this is adding an extra
constraint to my problem.
And doing this is challenging.
Thinking about what the right
constraint that would let you
solve your problem is tricky,
especially in the beginning.
But for now, let's just take
this as a thing that works.
Why does it work?
Because now I can say--
well, this term was fine, max--
so I'm trying to write longest
increasing subsequence starting
with the i-th letter, versus--
yeah, actually, no.
This is just going
to be different.
OK, so now I get to the
central issue, which is I
know, by the definition of L
of i, that I include letter i.
This is going to be in my
longest increasing subsequence.
That's what I'm looking
for, this definition.
But I don't know what
the second letter is--
could be i plus 1,
could be i plus 2,
could be anything bigger.
Whenever there's
something I don't know,
I'll just brute force it.
I don't care that I don't know.
I'll just take a max over
all the possible choices.
Let's say that the next
letter included in the longest
increasing subsequence i is j.
Then I would like
to look at L of j.
Now, I don't know what j is,
but I'll just brute force
all possible choices for j.
So that's going to be
i strictly less than j,
because I don't want include
the same letter i again.
And otherwise, I would get
an infinite recursive loop,
if I put less than
or equal to here.
And maybe I don't do
anything else to n.
OK, not quite done--
now-- this is the
interesting part--
I can enforce increasing,
because I can't just choose
any letter j to the right of i.
Also, the number-- or letter
that's written in here
has to be greater than the
number that's written here.
That's the strictly
increasing property.
So I can add as a constraint
in this max to say A of i
am strictly less than A of j.
And if you wanted
non-strictly increasing,
you would add an equal there.
This is mathematical notation.
In Python, you would say max
open paren of this thing for j
in this range, if this holds.
So I'm just doing for
loop, but I only do--
I only look at the
possible choices for j
when the strict
increasing property holds.
And then, when that
holds, I put-- check this.
Now, this set might be empty.
I need to define what the
max is when it's empty.
Oh, I also need a
1 plus, don't I?
Let me just do 1 plus.
So we're told that i is in the
answer, so we always get 1.
And then the remainder
is this or 0.
If there are no Aj's
greater than Ai,
then we'll default to 0 and
say that i is the only item
in my increasing subsequence.
OK, so there are a few
details to get right,
but in general, once you figure
out what these recurrences look
like, they're very simple.
This is one line of code, and
then all you need in addition
to this is the
original subproblem
and some other things.
We need the base cases, but
I should do them in order.
Topological order is
just the usual for loop,
because I'm doing suffixes.
It's going to be i equals
length of A down to 0.
Base case is going
to be L of length
of A, which is 0,
because there's
no letters in that suffix.
And we already did
O, and then time--
is a little different
from the past examples.
So number of subproblems,
just like usual,
is linear length
of A subproblems.
It's only one sequence
we're thinking about now,
unlike the previous example.
But the work we're
doing in this relation
now is non-trivial work.
Before we were just guessing
among two different choices.
Now we're guessing among
up to n different choices.
This n here is length of A.
And so we have
theta length of A,
non-recursive work that we're
doing in each subproblem.
Or you might think of this as
choices that we're considering.
And for each choice,
we're just spending--
I mean, we're just taking a
max of those items, adding 1.
So that's a constant overhead.
And so we just get this
product, which is A squared--
cool.
So that's longest
increasing subsequence.
Make sure I didn't
miss anything else--
so we're using this idea
of asking a question,
and guessing or brute
forcing the answer
to that question in two places.
One place is we're
promising-- we're
requesting that the longest
increasing subsequence starts
at i, so then the
question is, well,
what is the very
second item that's
in the longest increasing
subsequence that starts with i?
We're calling that
j, and we're brute
forcing all the possible
choices that j could be,
which conveniently
lets us check,
confirm that it's actually an
increasing subsequence locally
from i to j.
And then L of j will
take care of the rest.
By induction, the rest
of the longest increase
in subsequence starting at
j will also be increasing.
And so this guarantees, by
induction, the whole thing
will be increasing.
Then we also use this
local brute force
to solve the original problem.
So we added this constraint
of starting at i,
but we didn't actually know
overall where to start.
But that's fine, because
there's only A choices.
So I should mention, in
the running time analysis--
so they're solving
the subproblems.
That's fine, but
then there's also
a plus whatever it costs to
solve the original problem.
But that's OK.
That's length of A.
All of this plus length of A
is still length of A squared.
But if you're doing exponential
work here, that would be bad.
We have to do some
reasonable amount of work
to solve the original problem
in terms of all the subproblems.
I have an example hiding here.
This is a little
harder to stare at.
Here I have empathy.
And this example is not--
doesn't have much empathy,
because the longest increasing
subsequence of empathy
is empty.
Empty is one of the few English
words that's increasing.
And the hard part here
is drawing the DAG.
It's almost the complete
graph, but we only
draw edges from smaller
letters to bigger letters.
So we draw from E
to M, from E to P,
from E not to A-- there's
no edge from E to A-- from E
to T, not from E to H,
but yes from E to Y.
And then we also draw
from E to the base
case, which is there's
no more letters.
That edge to the base case is--
corresponds to this 0, or I
guess this n, where we say,
oh, let's just recurse.
Let's just throw away--
actually, maybe we don't need
the union 0 there, in fact,
because we include L of n,
which is the empty substring.
Then the definition of
L is a little funny.
What does it mean to say
you start with A of n?
Hm?
AUDIENCE: If we define A of n.
ERIK DEMAINE: Right,
A of n is not defined,
so that's not so nice.
So maybe fix that.
n equals case.
OK, but I'm still
going to draw an edge
there-- conceptually say, oh,
we're just done at that point.
That's the base case, where
we have no string left--
cool.
And when I said from to to
actually, I meant the reverse.
All the edges go
from right to left.
And then what we're doing
is looking for the longest
path in this DAG.
Longest path is maybe a problem
we've talked about in problem
session, because it's a DAG--
well, longest path is the
same thing as shortest path,
if you just negate
all the weights.
There are no weights
in this picture,
so if you just put negative
1 on all these edges
and ask for the shortest path
from the base to anywhere--
so single source shortest
paths from this base--
then we would end up
getting this path, which,
if you look at it,
is E-M-P-T-Y, empty.
And so that shortest path
is indeed the right answer.
What I've drawn here is
the shortest path tree.
So also, if you wanted the
longest increasing subsequence
starting at A, then it is
A-T-Y, just by following
the red arrows here.
And how do you get that?
You just draw the
parent pointers,
just like we did before.
I didn't mention, but
this example can also
be solved with shortest paths.
Once I construct this graph,
you can do the shortest path
from some base--
I don't know which one--
to here.
If you put negative 1 on
all of the diagonal edges
and you put weight
0 everywhere else,
then that corresponds to--
the shortest path
in that graph will
correspond to the longest--
the path with the
most diagonal edges.
And that makes sense, because
the diagonal is where we
actually get letters in common.
And so in this case, it's 2.
So both of these dynamic
programs could instead--
instead of writing them
as a recursive thing
with memoization or writing
them bottom-up as a for loop
and then doing the
computation, you
could instead construct
a graph and then
run DAG shortest paths on it.
But the point is these
are the same thing.
It's actually a lot
simpler to just write
the dynamic programming
code, because it's
just a for loop and
then a recurrence.
So you're just
updating an array.
Because you already know what
the topological order is,
you don't have to write a
generic depth for search
algorithm, take the
finishing order,
reverse it, and then run this--
run DAG shortest paths
with relaxation--
much simpler to just
write down the recurrence,
once you figured it out.
But they are the same
in these examples.
In Fibonacci, for example,
you cannot write Fibonacci
as a single source
shortest paths problem,
but a lot of DPs you can write
as shortest paths problem--
just a connection to
things we've seen.
All right, last example,
last problem for today--
we'll do more next week.
Alternating coin game--
this is a two player game.
We're going to find the
optimal strategy in this game.
In general, you have
a sequence of coins,
and we have two players.
They take turns.
So given coins of value
v0 to v n minus 1--
so it's a sequence.
They're given in order--
in some order-- for
example, 5, 10, 100,
25-- not necessarily
sorted order.
And the rules of the game are
we're going to take turns.
I'm going to take
turns with you.
I'm going to use I and you
to refer to the two players.
And so in each turn, either
one-- whoever's turn it is,
I get to--
we get to choose either the
first coin or the last coin
among the coins that remain.
So at the beginning,
I can choose 5 or 25.
And I might think,
oh, 25's really good.
That's better than 5.
I should choose that.
But then, of course,
you're going next,
and you're going to choose
100, and you'll win the game.
You'll get more of the
total value of the coins.
So in this is example,
a better strategy
is to take the 5, because then
the 100 is still in the middle.
And so once I take 5, you
get to choose 10 or 25.
At this point, you'd
probably prefer 25,
because that's better than 10.
But whichever you choose,
I can take the 100.
And so I get 105 points, and
you're going to get 35 points.
OK-- good example for me.
So that's easy for
a simple example,
but in general, there are
exponentially many strategies
here.
At each step, either of us
could go left or right--
choose is the leftmost
or the rightmost.
And we're going to give a
dynamic programming algorithm
that just solves this fast.
I didn't mention-- so this
algorithm is quadratic time,
but it can be made n log n time.
It's a fun exercise.
Using a lot of the data
structure augmentation stuff
we've done, you can
make this n log n.
This algorithm, I think, is
going to be n squared time.
So I won't right
the problem exactly,
but I think you know the rules.
Choose leftmost or rightmost
coin, alternating moves.
So I'd like to define
some subproblems.
And this is a problem that's
very naturally a substring
problem.
If I just looked at suffixes,
that would deal great with--
if I'm deleting coins from the
left, but as soon as I delete--
and if I delete coins
only from the right,
that would give me prefixes.
But I'll tell you now,
there's no dynamic programming
where the answer is
suffixes and prefixes.
You can do suffixes or
prefixes, but if you need both,
you almost certainly need
substring, because as soon
as I delete the first
coin, and then maybe you
take the second coin--
that's exactly the optimal
strategy here-- now
you have an arbitrary
substring in the middle.
But substrings are
enough, because we're only
leading from the ends.
We'll look at substrings.
So more precisely-- this
is just the intuition--
we're going to define
some generic x of i,
j is going to be what is
the maximum total value I
can get from this game, if we
play it on coins of value Vi
to Vj.
So that's a substring.
So this is one way to
write down the subproblems,
and it's also a good way.
You could write down a
relation on this definition
of subproblems.
But I'm low on time.
There's two ways to
solve this problem.
This is a reasonable
way, exploiting
that the game is zero-sum.
But I'd like to change just
a little bit to give you,
I think, what's a cleaner way
to solve the problem, which
is to add a third coordinate
to my subproblems.
So now it's parameterized
by three things.
P here is-- only
has two choices.
It's me or you.
And this gets at a point
that's maybe not totally
clear from this definition--
max total value that I can get
from these-- this substring
of coins.
But this is not
obviously what I need.
So obviously, at the beginning,
I want the whole string
and I want to know what my
maximum value is-- fine.
And I go first in this game.
I didn't specify, but I do.
[INAUDIBLE]
But as soon as I do a move-- as
soon as I take the first coin,
for example--
it's now your turn.
And so I don't really want to
know the maximum total value
that I would get if I go first.
I'd like to say, if
player P goes first.
I'd really like to
know what happens
in the case where you go first.
So for some of the
substrings, I want
to know what happens when you
go first, and for some of them,
I want to know what
happens when I go first,
because as soon as I make
a move, it's your turn.
And so we're going to flip back
and forth between P being me
and P being you--
P-U. So you don't
have to parameterize.
There's a way to write
the recurrence otherwise,
but this is, I think,
a lot more intuitive,
because now we can do a
very simple relation, which
is as follows.
So I'm going to
split into two cases.
One is x of i, j, me and
the other is x of i, j, you.
So x of i, j, me--
so I have some
substring from i to j.
What could I do?
I could take the first coin or
I could take the second coin.
Which should I do?
That's my question.
What is my first move?
Should I take the first
coin or the second coin?
So this is my question.
What is the first move?
There are exactly two possible
answers to that question,
so we can afford to just brute
force them and take the max.
If we're moving, we
want the maximum number
of points we can get-- maximum
total value of the two choices.
So if I take from the
i side, the left side,
that would be x sub i plus 1, j.
Sorry.
And now, crucially,
we flip players,
because then it's your turn.
And if I take from the j side,
that will make it j minus 1.
This is what I
accidentally wrote
at the beginning of lecture.
Also flip players.
So either I shrink on the i
side or I shrink on the j side.
Oh, I should add on here the
value of the coin that I get,
and add on the value
the coin that I took.
This is an expression
inside the max.
That sum.
And if I take the max those
two options, that will give--
that is my local brute force
the best choice of how many--
what are the total
value of coins
I will get out of the
remainder, given that you start,
plus this coin that I took
right now in the first step,
and for the two possible
choices of what that coin is?
OK, what remains is, how do
we define this x of i, j, you.
This is a little bit funnier,
but it's conceptually similar.
I'm going to write basically the
same thing here, but with me,
instead of you--
because again, it flips.
This is, if you go first, then
the very next move will be me.
So this is just the
symmetric formula here.
I can even put the braces in--
so far, the same.
Now, I don't put in the plus Vi
and I don't put in the plus Vj
here, because if you're moving,
I don't get those points.
So there's an asymmetry
in this definition.
You could define it
in different ways,
but this is the
maximum total value
that I would get if you start.
So in your first move,
you get some points,
but I don't get any
points out of that.
So there's no plus Vi.
There's no plus Vj.
It's just you either
choose the i-th coin
or you choose the j-th
coin, and then the coins
that remain for me
shrink accordingly.
Now, you're kind of
a pain in the ass.
You're an adversary
you're trying
to minimize my score
potentially because you're
trying to maximize your score.
This is a 0 sum game.
So anything that
you get I don't get.
If you want to
maximize your score,
you're trying to
minimize my score.
These are symmetric things.
And so if you think for a while,
the right thing to put here
is min.
From our perspective,
we're imagining
what is the worst case that
could happen, no matter
what you do.
And we don't have
control over what you do,
and so we'd really like
to see, what score would I
get if you chose the i-th coin?
What score do you get if
you chose the j-th coin?
And then what we get is going
to be the worst of those two
possibilities.
So when we get to
choose, we're maximizing.
And this is a general
two player phenomenon
that, when you choose,
we end up minimizing,
because that's the saddest
thing that could happen to us.
OK, this is one way to
write a recurrence relation.
We have, of course,
all of SRTBOT to do,
so the topological order
here is in increasing length
of substance.
So the T is
increasing j minus i.
Start with empty strings.
So base case is that
x of i, i, me is Vi.
So here I'm inclusive in
both ends in this definition.
So there is a coin I
can take at the end.
But if you move last and
there's one coin left,
then I don't get it, so it's 0.
Then we have the original
problem that is x i, j, me--
sorry-- x 0, n.
That's the entire coin
set, starting with me.
That was the problem
I wanted to do.
And then the running time we get
is the number of subproblems--
that's theta n squared, because
we're doing substrings--
times the amount of
non-recursive work I do here.
That's just a max
of two numbers.
Very simple.
Constant time.
So this is quadratic.
Let me show you an example.
This is hard to draw, but
what I've described here
is called solution
2 in the notes.
So here's our sequence--
5, 10, 100, 25--
in both directions.
And what we're interested
in is all substrings.
So over here I've
written the choice for i.
So we start at one of these,
and if you start here,
you can't end
earlier than there.
So that's why we're in the
upper diagonal of this matrix.
And then there's two
versions of each problem--
the white version
and the blue version
just down and to
the right of it.
If you can't see
what blue is, this
is the version where you start.
This is the version
where I start.
And I've labeled here all
of the different numbers.
Please admire, because this
took a long time to draw.
But in particular,
we have 105 here,
meaning that the maximum
points I can get 105.
And that's the case because,
if we look over there,
it is the max of these
two incoming values
plus the Vi that I get.
So either I go to the left and
I take that item or I go down
and I take that item.
So the option here is I
went to the left and took--
well, that's going to
be tricky to do in time.
The claim is that
the best answer here
is to go here with the 100 and
take the 5, because going down
corresponds to
removing the last item.
If I went to the left,
that corresponds to--
sorry-- the first item.
If I went to the
left, that corresponds
to removing the last
item, so my options
are 10 plus 25, which is
35, versus 100 plus 5.
105 wins, so that's why
there's a red edge here showing
that was my better choice.
And in general, if you follow
these parent pointers back,
it gives you the optimal
strategy in what you should do.
First, you should take the 5 is
what this is saying, because we
just clipped off the 5.
We used to start
here, and now we
start here in this subinterval.
Then our opponents, to be
annoying, will take the 25--
doesn't actually
matter, I think.
Then we will take the
100, and then they
take the 10, and it's game over.
OK, all the numbers
here are how many points
we get-- doesn't say how many
points the opponent gets.
Of course, you could
add that as well.
It's just the total
sum minus what we get.
Now, let me come back
to high level here.
What we're really doing
is subproblem expansion,
and this is an idea that we
will expand on next lecture.
And the idea is
that sometimes you
start with the obvious
subproblems of prefixes,
suffixes, or substrings.
Here, the obvious
version was substrings,
because we were
moving from both ends.
If you don't know, probably
suffixes or prefixes
are enough.
So we start there,
but sometimes that's
still not enough subproblems.
Here, as soon as we made
a move, our problem almost
turned upside-down,
because now it's
your turn, instead of my turn.
And that was just
annoying to deal with,
and so we could-- whenever you
run into a new type of problem,
just build more subproblems.
As long as it stays
polynomial number,
we'll get polynomial time.
And so here we doubled
the number of subproblems
to just the me case
and the you case,
and that made this recurrence
really easy to write.
In the notes, you'll see
a messier way to write it,
if you don't do that.
In the examples we'll
see next lecture,
we're going to do a
lot more expansion,
maybe multiplying the number
of problems by n or n squared.
And this will give us--
it will let us add more
constraints to our subproblems,
like we did in longest
increasing subsequence.
We added this constraint that
we start with a particular item.
The more subproblems we have, we
can consider more constraints,
because we'll just brute force
all the possible constraints
that could apply.
Well, we'll see more
of that next time.
That's it for today.